COUNTRY, THE FASCINATING
DOCUMENTARY IS ON
FOXNation.com RIGHT NOW.
WE MADE A PRETTY OBVIOUS
SUGGESTION ON THE SHOW LAST
NIGHT, WHY DON'T WE HAVE
CIVILIAN REVIEW BOARDS FOR OUR
SCHOOLS?
IT'S NOT LIKE SCHOOLS AREN'T
IMPORTANT, THERE MAY BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE PAY FOR.
IN A LOT OF PLACES THEY ARE THE
MAIN THING WE PAY FOR, THE
BIGGEST BUDGET ITEM IN MOST
TOWNS, SCHOOLS.
WE ARE EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN TO
BECOME ADULTS AND RUN THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY ARE
INHERITING.
SO WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CLASSES?
WHY DON'T WE HAVE CAMERAS IN
EVERY CLASSROOM?
AGAIN, IT'S OBVIOUS, WE HAVE
CAMERAS MONITORING CONGRESS,
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS, OUR
POLICE OFFICERS ARE REQUIRED TO
WEAR CAMERAS.
WHAT'S THE ARGUMENT AGAINST
THAT?
SO WHY SHOULD WE HAVE CAMERAS IN
THE CLASSROOM?
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER, USED TO
BE THAT WHICH IS TRUSTED WITH
THEIR TEACHING OUR KIDS.
NOW WE KNOW A LOT OF THEM ARE
DEMENTED AND THEY ARE TEACHING
POISON.
THE BIGGEST TEACHERS UNIT IN THE
COUNTRY HAS COME OUT IN SUPPORT
OF RACIST STRUGGLE SESSIONS IN
KINDERGARTEN.
MEANWHILE, THE VIDEO WE DO HAVE
IS NOT REASSURING AT ALL.
OVER THE PAST YEAR YOU'VE SEEN
ALL KINDS OF CELL PHONE FOOTAGE
WITH TEACHERS SAYING SHOCKING
THINGS, BERATING VACCINATED
STUDENTS, FOR EXAMPLE, FOR NOT
WEARING THEIR OBEDIENCE MASKS.
WATCH.
>> I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
VACCINATED, YOU LITTLE
[INDISCERNIBLE].
I DON'T WANT TO GET SICK AND
DIE.
>> OKAY.
>> THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE YOU
CAN INFECT JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE
VACCINATED.
YOU'RE NOT A SPECIAL PERSON
AROUND HERE.
YOU SHOULD HEAR ABOUT HOW
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT -- YOU'RE
A JERK!
YOU'RE A JERK!
>> Tucker: YEAH, THAT'S
TOTALLY NORMAL.
SO WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN CLASSROOMS?
WHAT'S THE ANSWER, WHY SHOULDN'T
WE?
AND NOT SURPRISING, A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE VERY OFFENDED BY
THIS.
YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW,
SHUT UP AND SEND YOUR KIDS.
DON'T ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE LEARNING, ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE THEY ARE
BECOMING.
[AWKWARD LAUGH]
MATT WALSH HOSTS THE MAT WHILE
SHOW.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
THIS IS ONE OF THESE THINGS THAT
SOMEONE SUGGESTED TO ME IN
CONVERSATION THE OTHER MORNING.
THE SECOND EYE THIRD AT I
THOUGHT THAT'S THE MOST OBVIOUS
THING I EVER HEARD, WHY DON'T WE
DO THAT?
WHY DON'T WE DO THAT, I GUESS,
LET ME ASK YOU THAT QUESTION.
>> WELL, I MEAN FIRST OF ALL I
HAVE TO ADMIT THE REFORM I WOULD
PREFER FOR THE PUBLICS WILL
SYSTEM IS TO JUST DESTROY IT,
REFORM IT WITH A WRECKING BALL.
I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD EXIST AT
ALL BUT IF IT'S GOING TO EXIST,
THEN IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE SHOULD WANT TO KNOW
WHAT OUR KIDS ARE BEING TAUGHT
WHEN THEY'RE IN THESE GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS.
MAYBE THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS
WHO DON'T WANT TO CONFRONT OR
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT EXACTLY THEY'RE
DOING WHEN THEY SEND THEIR KIDS
TO PUBLIC SCHOOL.
YOU'RE SENDING THEM TO A
GOVERNMENT BUILDING FOR SEVEN
HOURS A DAY, FIVE DAYS A WEEK,
NINE MONTHS A YEAR FOR 12 YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
YOU SHOULD WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON, WHAT'S GOING ON INSIDE
THE BUILDING WHEN THEY ARE THERE
ALL THAT TIME.
I THINK THERE'S A REASON --
THERE'S THE REAL REASON WHY THE
LEFT DOESN'T WANT THIS AND THEN
THERE'S THE REASON THAT THEY
GIVE US, WHICH OF COURSE OFTEN
TIMES ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
THE REASON THEY GIVE US IS IT'S
A PRIVACY CONCERN OR IT'S A
FREE -- IT'S EVEN A FREE-SPEECH
CONCERN.
FIRST OF ALL, TEACHERS AS
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
WORKING WITH KIDS, THEY
SHOULDN'T GET PRIVACY OR
FREE SPEECH ANY MORE THAN I WANT
A BANK TELLER -- IF I'M MAKING A
DEPOSIT OF A LOT OF CASH, I
DON'T WANT THEM TO TURN THE
CAMERAS OFF AND GO INTO A BACK
ROOM AND SAY I NEED SOME PRIVACY
WHILE I DO THIS.
WE DON'T WANT PRIVACY IN THEIR
CAPACITY HANDLING MONEY.
YOU SEND YOUR DOG TO A DOG
BORDER, THEY GOT WEBCAMS NOW SO
YOU CAN CHECK IN ANYTIME.
SO WHY WOULDN'T WE WANT THAT
KIND OF OVERSIGHT WITH KIDS?
AND I THINK THE REAL REASON,
ASIDE FROM THE REASONS THEY GIVE
US COME OUT THE REAL REASON IS
THAT THEY JUST -- THEY DON'T
WANT US TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
INSIDE THE BUILDING.
AS YOU SAID, WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW.
>> Tucker: LET'S BE TOTALLY
BLUNT HERE.
MOST TEACHERS ARE GREAT, I AM
MARRIED TO A FORMER TEACHER.
BUT SOME TEACHERS ARE CREEPY.
AND WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO TALK TO OTHER PEOPLE'S
PREPUBESCENT KIDS ABOUT SEX IN
PRETTY DETAILED WAYS.
YOUR CREEP IF YOU DO THAT, LET'S
BECOME TOTALLY CLEAR ABOUT IT.
ANYONE WOULD WANT TO TALK TO A
THIRD-GRADER ABOUT
"FOX NEWS PRIMETIME"'S, DON'T
YOU THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
CAMERA ON THE PERSON?
>> THAT'S ANOTHER THING WHERE
THAT SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING AT
ALL EVEN WITH A CAMERA.
SO WE SHOULD HAVE THAT KIND OF
OVERSIGHT.
I THINK IF THERE'S ANYTHING --
JUST THINK OF IT LIKE THIS, IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT COULD HAPPEN
INSIDE A PUBLIC SCHOOL CLASSROOM
THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY WOULD NOT
WANT ON FILM, AND IF YOU CAN
THINK OF SOMETHING THAT COULD
HAPPEN LIKE THAT, IT SHOULDN'T
BE HAPPENING IN THE CLASSROOM TO
BEGIN WITH.
WHATEVER'S HAPPENING THERE
SHOULD BE OPEN FOR ANYONE TO SEE
OR AT LEAST AS YOU KNOW, YOU CAN
HAVE THE CAMERAS IN THEIR AND
PARENTS WHO HAVE CUSTODY OF
CHILDREN COULD HAVE -- THEY
COULD BE PASSWORD-PROTECTED.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS OF DOING
THIS THAT MAKE A LOT OF SENSE I
THINK.
>> Tucker: BUT YOUR POINT IS
THE BEST POINT AND I WISH I'D
SAID IT.
IF THERE IS SOMETHING HAPPENING
A PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT SHOULDN'T
BE ON FILM, IT SHOULDN'T BE
HAPPENING